il nous sommes maintenant en
communication avec un informaticien il
se trouve dans la région le sud de la
république démocratique du congo il a 37
ans il s'agit de pierre mvolo foba qui
est un bon soir vous avez une question
qui porte sur la géographie canadienne
en fait sur la géographie politique
canadienne et c'est sur une région de
l'ouest du canada qui bordent l'océan
pacifique
c'est comme prendre comme on couvert
c'est ça voilà vous avez pas un peu
quand même la réponse à votre question
donc ça c'est votre indice et il est bon
la population chinoise au canada est
pincée de 300000 personnes en 1981 à
plus 2 millions à partir de 2001 et une
portion de cette population est allé
s'établir sur la côte ouest canadienne
dans la région de vancouver pas
nécessairement au centre-ville de
vancouver mais à vancouver comme tel et
dans les banlieues aisées
il ya eu tellement donc une augmentation
rapide de ces nouveaux arrivants qu'on
est arrivé avec ce terme péjoratif c'est
négatif en parler de vancouver comme
étant rome couvin c'est un terme qui est
sortir au début des années 90 on
l'entendait beaucoup ça circule
énormément aujourd'hui un petit peu
moins c'est pas politiquement correct
peut-être que ça marquait une
frustration à l'époque où on sentait que
la communauté asiatique
lorsqu'elle arrivait elle ne s'intégrait
pas elles se regroupent elle se
retournait en noyaux sur elle même
il ya eu beaucoup de frustration de la
part des blancs qui était alors
majoritaire une sur cette portion du
canada dès le départ gare ou sans
25 cents trente ans on a pensé
construire un chemin de fer au canada
qu'on appelle le chemin fer
transcanadien et on s'est tourné vers
l'immigration asiatique pour pouvoir
combler les besoins en personnel qui
était prêt à travailler des heures
épouvantables dans des conditions très
difficiles
pas souvent respectueuse de l'être
humain et après ça le canada s'est
refermée complètement à l'immigration
asiatique comme le canada s'est refermée
à l'immigration ne s'est pas ouvert en
tête à l'immigration africaine entre
1920 et jusqu'à en 1981 par 4 en 1960
qu'elle quelques vous étiez africains
vous étiez noir on vous étiez pas
vraiment le bienvenu au canada donc
l'immigration aujourd'hui pour répondre
à votre question asiatiques elle est
choisie quand il a été question du
retour de la colline d'hommes comme dans
les mains des chinois en 1997 lorsque
l'entente coloniale a pris fin bien vous
avez dans les années précédant tout à
fait au début des années 90 beaucoup de
ces immigrants dont akon qui ont dit on
va aller s'installer au canada pour y
rester on ne savait pas mais au moins
pour avoir une sécurité avoir un
passeport canadien au cas où les choses
tournent mal
dans une ville comme une conne sous
régime chinois mais les choses se sont
bien passées depuis
on sait que quand il ya un statut
spécial et plusieurs immigrants qui
était venu au canada sont maintenant
retourner mais plusieurs d'entre eux
sont restés ce qui est important de
savoir c'est que la plupart d'entre eux
ont conservé leurs passeports canadiens
n'ont pas voulu s'en départir
parce que c'est un atout on ne sait
jamais ce qui pourrait se passer dans
l'avenir on a pour vous des extraits
d'un reportage qui a été diffusé en 1996
alors que beaucoup de citoyens à
vancouver se plaignaient de cette
arrivée massive de citoyens de hong kong
avant la rétrocession de hong kong aux
mains du gouvernement chinois
alors si vous voulez bien on va écouter
ça ensemble ça vous donner une idée de
des émotions qui traversait cette ville
à ce moment là et qui encore aujourd'hui
teinte un petit peu les conversations
d'accord
tous les jours plus de cent mille
personnes regardent ce bulletin de
nouvelles pertes civiles de vancouver
est une station bilingue cantonais et
mandarin attention ce n'est pas un poste
communautaire c'est une station
commerciale qui diffuse 20 heures par
jour qui emploie 90 personnes et qui
rapportent de l'argent à ses
propriétaires des chinois de hong kong
[Musique]
les plus grandes compagnies font de la
publicité sur les zones de forte chaleur
et vivent les migrants chinois sont plus
à l'aise financièrement et des dépenses
plus donc toronto dominion sprint canada
mercedes cathay pacific
toutes ces compagnies utilisent
fairchild tivi pour rejoindre une
clientèle de choix
les milliers de chinois qui arrivent les
poches pleines de dollars pour s'établir
dans la grande région de vancouver
[Musique]
cette année seulement trente mille
chinois venant de hong kong et de taiwan
immigrantes à vancouver ils viennent
s'ajouter aux 260 milles qui vivent déjà
dans la région
l'année prochaine ils seront de nouveau
30000 à venir ici l année d'après encore
rapide
un beau contrat pour les deux parties
dont bien que l'intégration des nouveaux
arrivés n'est pas si facile je crains
que les gens restent sinois sincèrement
parce que c'est très difficile de
s'intégrer
on parle quand on est autant les gens si
noir carte leurs traditions leurs
moteurs de forme de pensée et donc et
elle est très difficile de s'en aller
merci beaucoup nous avons posé cette
question pierre sur un phénomène de
société dans l'ouest du canada
alors c'était monsieur pierre volot foba
qui se trouvent en république
démocratique du congo